et en france elle n'hésite et une petite
dizaine à se rassembler autour d'un
pique nique pour réclamer à la
libération de julian assange et coûtait
quelques participants ça fait deux ans
que je lutte pour la libération de
julian assange qui est c'est pas mon
avis c'est une opinion largement
partagée
la ferme de presse la plus importante du
siècle mois et camarades ici on n'a pas
l'intention de ne pas marquer le coup
pour julian assange lui dire qu'il n'est
pas seul ça on le sait est en tout cas
qu'on la bande en a pas la lutte jusqu'à
ce qu'il soit libre ça c'est clair
je pense qu'il ya quand même une idée
avec cet anniversaire de dire quand même
aux gens que c'est pas un combat perdu
d'abord que il ya encore il dépend de la
mobilisation
l'opinion est donc ça c'est quand même
quelque chose il faut pas oublier je
défend la cause d'assange depuis très
longtemps bien avant qu'ils ne soient
enlevés de l'ambassade et est incarcéré
parce que c'est une cause qui me semble
élémentaire pour toute personne
soucieuse de la liberté d'informer et
liberté d'expression la liberté et le
droit même de dénoncer des crimes et les
agissements de l' empire américain
donc c'est une cause qui me semble
évidente mais je constate que
malheureusement c'est pas le cas pour
toutes les forces politiques
associatives syndicales
je le déplore mais bon il n'est jamais
trop tard pour pour rejoindre le combat